grazie
benvenuti
siete bellissimi
è un vero piacere per me un vero onore
essere qui oggi a
proporvi
i risultati di un progetto che ho
intrapreso all'incirca dieci mesi fa che
si potrebbe anche
si potrebbe anche vedere come una sorta
di esperimento sociale
l'idea è nata tre anni fa all'incirca
tre anni fa è
praticamente
alla base di questo progetto ci sta una
una scoperta che ho fatto circa tre anni
fa l'uomo è buono
voglio dirlo ancora l'uomo è buono
anche la donna
e diciamo che
una volta che ho
diciamo
preso convinzione di questa cosa quello
che dovevo fare era trovare un modo per
diffonderla il più possibile diffondere
il più possibile
al maggior numero di persone possibili
in tutte le sue sfaccettature è anche
nel maggior numero di lingue possibili
si sa che le cose le idee migliori
spesso sono quelle più semplici quindi
non ho fatto altro che prendere la
vicenda che mi ha ispirato
e elevarla all'ennesima potenza
ciò di cui avevo bisogno quindi la
ricetta la ricetta di cui avevo bisogno
erano tante persone il più possibile a
migliaia
un'infinità di situazioni e posti
diversi
e una persona che credesse ciecamente
nello spirito di questo progetto nella
montale l'uomo è visto che per ovvie
ragioni la mia condizione rispondeva
all'esigenza di fiducia c'è una battuta
fiducia cieca
questo è visto anche che non sono mai
stato una persona affetta di mania di
parte di protagonismo anche qua c'è
battuta ho deciso che quella persona ero
io
a questo punto faccio un salto indietro
nel passato faccio un salto indietro per
esporre in maniera chiara e lineare
tutto l'accaduto
cinque anni fa era un ragazzo normale
avevo 23 anni è una bellissima famiglia
un lavoro il mio la mia passione il mio
sport era il paracadutismo e avevo un
debole per le donne insomma ci sta
quel periodo era da poco uscito il
calendario di belen in un giorno sono
andato in edicola
l'ho comprato sono tornato a casa sono
andate in bagno e ci sono stato un po
troppo
adesso
e pensavo che si trattasse di leggende
metropolitane hai mai
stasera chissà quanti calendari saranno
comunque niente è successo questo visto
che comunque
mi è stato chiesto di venire a
raccontare una storia avvincente e
appassionante
adesso vi dirò invece che il 7 marzo del
2009 sono stato protagonista di un grave
incidente di paracadutismo
durante il quale nella fase
d'atterraggio impiattato ho impattato
violentemente
al suolo
se adesso qualcuno di voi si sta
domandando
chissà se si aperto il paracadute
la risposta è no del paracadute non si è
aperto io sono superman e stamattina ho
attraversato la dice la vice camminando
ho avuto questo brutto incidente sono
stato trasportato in condizioni
gravissime all'ospedale
fortunatamente dottori fantastici
infermiere meravigliose mi hanno
inosservato anche avuto ha giocato un
ruolo fondamentale anche la mia famiglia
che mi è stata molto vicino dopo circa
due settimane di coma farmacologico si
sono resi conto della mia cecità
nonostante non avesse battuto la testa
comunque ero ancora non era il primo dei
problemi dopo circa un mese sono stato
dichiarato fuori pericolo e niente tra
lacrime e sorrisi
ho portato avanti la mia degenza
ospedaliera cercando di
rimettermi in sesto
dopo cinque mesi sono stato rispedito a
casa con la carrozzeria che era più o
meno sistemata e ero comunque ancora col
problema della vista è risolto e non mi
hanno neanche data stato neanche è stata
data una spiegazione certa
nonostante questo l'area di casa mi ha
fatto bene ho iniziato a stare meglio
essere più tranquillo non ero comunque
completamente
sereno perché era la prima volta che mi
capitava di perdere la vista
non c'ero ancora abituato
una cosa molto importante è arrivata
circa un anno dall'incidente ho
partecipato a un seminario molto
importante sulle facoltà del cervello
tenuto da una francese di tutto pepe
michel
19 comunque che mi ha praticamente
aperto un mondo seminario appunto sulle
facoltà del cervello ti ho acquisito gli
strumenti che mi servivano per
comprendere tante cose sulla mia vita
presente e passata e durante lo
svolgersi di questo seminario che è
durato circa
44 incontri in cinque mesi
ho sperimentato a livello pratico che
queste cose che mi stavano che mi
venivano insegnate erano vere
funzionavano è uno dei principi
tantissime cose mi sono state segnalate
comunque una delle cose più interessanti
è che il nostro cervello è uno strumento
potentissimo
e che con il nostro pensiero non sono in
grado di influenzare la realtà che ci
circonda e questa è una cosa fantastica
è talmente semplice che è meravigliosa e
quindi ho iniziato pian piano partendo
la prima con un po di scetticismo poi
mi sono reso conto che le cose
funzionavano e ho anche imparato allo
stesso tempo che fare del bene per gli
altri è uno è una delle cose che più può
nobilitare nobilitare la nostra vita è
una delle cose per cui vale la pena
spendersi quindi iniziamo a dare una
mano a
così agli altri al prossimo tra varie
associazioni eccetera eccetera ho anche
iniziato rendi conto che la vita pian
piano diventava sempre più bella e
questo misero qua fino a pochi mesi
prima
lo reputavo
impossibile da ritrovare caffè insomma
avevo sperimentato una condizione mai
mai provata prima
ceco sul letto non potevo morley ero
afono avevo perso tutto avevo solamente
cuore e cervello che funzionavano e
quindi avevo sperimentato che cosa
significa perdere tutto da questa
condizione ogni piccola conquista ogni
piccolo traguardo che ho raggiunto sono
stati per me vissuti con un grande
entusiasmo e ricordo ancora la prima
volta che ovviamente una delle prime
cose che si cercano l'autonomia quando
si si prende la visto che quando ci si
trova in una situazione che
rende disabili perché è questo che mi è
successo
e ricordo ancora la prima volta che ho
percorso 300 metri circa 300 metri da
solo stavo tornando dalla palestra
c'era un percorso ciclopedonale che
tagliava tra i campi e si frapponeva più
o meno tra la palestra e casa mia ho
chiesto a mia mamma di portarmi
all'inizio di questo percorso e di
ascoltarmi dall'altra parte
subito lei non voleva però
non ci ho messo molto a farle capire che
era quello che volevo fare quindi lei a
partita ho percorso questi 300 metri da
solo a piedi
primi 300 metri fuori di casa da quando
avevo perso la vista e vi posso
assicurare che l'emozione provata in
questi percorrendo questi 300 metri
arrivando alla fine di questo percorso
non so se si può definire non si può non
so se si può paragonare a l'emozione che
ho provato
tornando a casa la scorsa settimana dopo
circa 80 mila chilometri in giro per
vari continenti quindi alla fine
possiamo renderci conto che non è
importante quanto si fa ma importante
come lo si fa e in che circostanze
e
quindi
un incidente
questo il calendario si
diciamo che
ecco una volta diciamo
recuperato tutte queste mie
l'autonomia anche la capacità di
muovermi circa due anni dopo ecco che
c'è stato l'evento al fatto che ha
ispirato questo questo mio progetto
questo mio viaggio volevo andare a
trovare i dottori e le infermiere
dell'ospedale dove era stato ricoverato
anche perché mi ha detto che erano molto
carina infermiere e
il problema è che quando sono arrivato
in treno a cesena sono sceso dal treno e
mi sono reso conto che mi ero
dimenticato di prenotare il servizio di
assistenza di trenitalia un servizio con
cui ero abituato a muovermi fino a quel
giorno e che ti accompagna da dove partì
fino a dove arrivi quindi mi sono
trovato da solo per la prima volta in un
posto che non conoscevo
e anziché farmi prendere dal panico ho
detto ok ci arriviamo facciamo come mi
hanno insegnato e vediamo cosa succede
e quello che successe meraviglioso
successo che dopo i primi passi con
iniziato a muovere la gente venuta da me
ne ha invitato dall altra non sono
arrivato è uscito sono uscito dalla
stazione dalla stazione preso un taxi e
taxi mi ha portato in ospedale
la gente tutta la gente che ho
incontrato lungo questi spostamenti ne
ha aiutato
ho raggiunto tutti i reparti che devo
raggiungere ho passato un po di tempo
quelle persone che volevo incontrare da
cesena sono arrivato a ravenna dove
incontrato dove c'è il centro di
paracadutismo in cui ho avuto
l'incidente e ho incontrato i miei amici
e da ravenna sono tornato a casa 1 gara
tutto questo in una maniera che fino
prima d'allora non avevo mai
sperimentato per me quella sera è stata
turbinio di emozioni di pensieri perché
quello che stavo iniziando a realizzare
era era importante ho realizzato che
potevo muovermi per tutti questi posti
senza pianificare senza appoggiarmi in
maniera
programmata all'aiuto di nessuno ma
semplicemente facendo militare dalla
gente che incontravo
e adesso non so dirvi con precisione se
in un minuto e in una settimana
in quanto tempo si sono svolti tutti i
miei
casino che ho avuto in testa però detto
come sono andato a cesena posso
spostarmi per qualsiasi altra città
possa girare tutta l'italia
posso girare per tutta l'europa
perché sono sempre stato un tipo
ambizioso e quindi ho detto visto che ci
siamo facciamo il giro del mondo
e la cosa era talmente incredibile per
me
importante e bella che ho detto che
valeva la pena di diffondere questa
notizia il fatto che io potevo girare il
mondo da solo con gli altri proprio
perché l'uomo è buono ho detto questo
talmente belle e talmente importanti che
devo farlo sapere a tutti e quindi
giro al mondo
con un blog dove racconto tutte le mie
avventure le mie vicende
e
questo quello che ho iniziato a fare
sono partito il 2 di aprile del 2013
dello scorso anno
se ora qualcuno si sta domandando da
dove sono partito
io sono pronto a scommettere che si
tratta delle stesse persone che prima
pensavano che il paracadute non si era
aperto e risponderò se non tradito da
timbuctu
visto che volevo partire da timbuctu
visto che non so dove sia sono partito
da casa mia
sono partito dalla casa mia dopo
l'italia sono andato in francia a parigi
già in francia di viaggio è cominciato
in maniera abbastanza emozionante nel
senso che la persona che in teoria mi
aspettava perché all'inizio del viaggio
e rossi convinto che questa cosa era
fattibile ero assolutamente convinto non
sapevo bene come però avrei fatto perché
non avevo mai fatto una cosa del genere
quindi per i primi spostamenti mi hanno
organizzato con persone che già stavano
nella mia prossima destinazione già mi
aspettavano invece è partito tutto in
contrario sono arrivato parigi è la
persona che mi aspettava mi ha aspettato
e quindi girando la sera per parigi
non è facile trovare un posto economico
gira di qua gila di là alla fine ecco
che lo spirito del mio viaggio si
materializza subito in un ragazzo
incontrato quasi per caso con il
tassista che alla fine avendosi
rendendosi conto che era difficile per
me trovare una sistemazione ospitato a
casa sua
questo è stato la prima notte ha detto
cavolo si inizia così meglio con la pa
visita una casa perché tutti i piani
falliti
e invece no ha continuato da parigi mi
sono spostato a ficcare in spagna dove
mi aspettavo un amico la figueres dopo
qualche giorno sono andato in passato da
barcellona per andare fino a madrid
madrid un altro gruppo di amici mi ha
accolto granada un altro ragazzo che
conoscevo da granada
mi sono spostato fino al confino alla
spiaggia la costa la costa sud della
spagna sono sceso in africa sono partito
dal marocco
anche a tangeri c'è un ragazzo che
conoscevo e diciamo che in questa
maniera dal marocco fino al benin ha
proseguito
via terra incontrando tutte persone che
più o meno già conoscevo
lungo questo percorso
ho sperimentato
vuol dire ho avuto varie esperienze mi
sono spostato in autobus mi sono
spostato con i taxi condivisi che è uno
degli amici è l'unica maniera che si
possono trovare in africa se ci si vuole
spostare via terra in certe zone
esperienza di tutti i tipi difficili
simpatiche
particolari quando per esempio siamo un
partito da
banjul la capitale del gambia per andare
in guinea dopo pochi poche ore di
viaggio
abbiamo investito qualcosa
e mentre tutti erano intenti a pregare e
chiedere perdono
io sono stato interpellato da penso
fossero poliziotti sono stato
consultato come testimone oculare
ha detto mi dispiace ragazzi ma non per
cattiveria ma non posso rispondervi
diciamo che
l'africa è stato il primo
primo posto che ha viaggiato dopo
l'africa sono rientrato velocemente in
italia per un matrimonio dopo l'italia
c'è stata l'asia
senza dilungarsi tra i vari problemi di
visti incontrati eccetera eccetera il
pacifico
sono rientrato nei sui nel sud est
asiatico è finito il pacifico una volta
giunto in laos circa qualche settimana
fa mi sono spostato in thailandia
perché qualcuno mi ha detto che c'era un
evento importante partecipare oggi
quindi oggi sono qua il viaggio continua
e
che dire l'ultimo messaggio che potrei
dire lanciare credete nei vostri sogni
non pensate che i limiti li possono
formare se siete in grado di gestire i
limiti dentro di voi
è un gioco quindi buona vita buon
divertimento
e grazie a tutti